les sentiers nature de schütz à philippe
dans les hautes laurentides ses 25 km de
sentiers aménagés par des citoyennes
dans la forêt publique
parmi eux andré chevalier où on a fait
un petit 2 qu'il ait la bottine stade à
avoir en tête que j'allais attaquer un
autre 2 qu'il avait jetée au mollet à 80
ans il s'apprête à défendre son héritage
contre l'exploitation forestière il va
orienter ici c'est par la force
donc c'est cette partie qui m'adresser
pensez vous que la chute d'adam
s'échapper d'accès pour les
renseignements qu'on eut ce qui avait
une coupe qui étaient près de fait cet
automne la municipalité demande un
moratoire sur la coupe
le temps de démontrer au gouvernement
qu'il ne fait pas une bonne affaire
nous ça fait au dessus de 400 à 1000
qu'on met en deux ans autant pour le
chemin que pour la bâtisse pour les
aménagements pour une coupe qui va
remporter 5000 10000 andré chevalier lui
est prêt à tout pour empêcher l'abattage
ce que j'ai trouvé voir cette clarté des
cui dalin s'est pas démobilisé s'ils
essaient de la dissidence a pallié par
les lois
la dissidence le militant écologiste
henri jacob connaît bien ça on est
présent dans des sentiers qu'on aménage
et qu'on appelle licenciés de l'école
buissonnière c'est en créant des
sentiers qu'il y est parvenu à préserver
ce bout de forêt à val d'or c'était dans
le but d' mètres des bois dans des roues
l exploitation forestière chacon
d'aménager des sentiers est oui place
qui voulaient aller faire de la récolte
et c'était plus 1983 donc c'est
probablement la plus vieille à aire
protégée du québec lorsque le
gouvernement le goût a désigné 17 % du
territoire du québec aires protégées en
décembre henri jacob avait espoir que ce
genre d'action citoyenne ne soit plus
nécessaire
ils déplorent aujourd'hui que le
territoire protégé soit peu accessible
on a eu aussi du 40ième 0.8 %
d'augmentation alors que 99 points 2 %
étaient dans le dans le bois fut pas
juste des deux par quatre ambroise
licques et directeur du plus récent parc
national du québec
le parco pemmican a été inauguré il y a
deux ans au témiscamingue
est-ce que vous fait pas aussi ben ça
amène de l'activité économique
nos parcs nationaux t on un parc
national
globalement pour chaque jour visite
c'est à peu près une soixantaine de
dollars de retombées
pourtant le parc a été créé à force de
compromis
le parc national dominicain c'est pas un
parc en un seul tenant c'est un parent
qui est morcelé donc comment est ce
qu'on peut lui confier aux activités
déjà en place sur le territoire
il y avait des activités des projets
hydroélectriques
il y avait des activités forestières le
parco pemmican ici c'est une longue et
lente opération le maire de val-d'or
était aux premières loges des
négociations lorsque le gouvernement du
québec a donné le feu vert à la création
du parc pierre corbeil était alors
ministre de la forêt je pense que c'est
devenu un outil de développement
économique qui est différent de la
transformation mais qui a qui doit
exister aussi il sait plus que quiconque
que la conciliation entre l'industrie
forestière et ceux qui veulent préserver
les milieux naturels requiert son lot
patience
les gens meurent avant à protéger j'en
ai besoin d'une jambe
javelot c'est comme ça ça marche pas
comme ça
selon lui pour être plus efficace le
gouvernement devrait faire davantage
confiance aux gens qui vivent sur les
territoires convoités
parce que je compare souvent ça que
c'est le territoire forestier en trop
c'est notre gagne pain
mais c'est aussi notre terrain de jeu
h et saint-philippe les citoyens
cherchent aussi cet équilibre pour
l'instant il semble difficile à trouver
coupe forestière un moteur de
développement on y croire vraiment il
faut qu'ils aient un besoin du milieu
pour que la coupe soit valable
la lutte leur cercle bien-être des
citoyens et le profit des entreprises ça
touchera même pose en moins d'un an que
les dividendes versés aux actionnaires
que dans le piège à rat emprunt secrecy
de délais trop longs pour les
actionnaires à voter du tout
et c'est valérie gamache radio canada
soutient philippe
[Musique]